So let's say you have
a website, and you also
built an app for a more
seamless experience on mobile.
As people share and follow
web links to your content
on Android, they will
normally see this speed bump
that we call a
disambiguation dialogue.
It's shown when the user has
many apps on their device
which can handle the
same type of link,
in this case, one containing
your domain and the URL.
But wouldn't it
be great if users
who follow a link to a
website that you own get
sent directly to your app?
My name is Wojtek
Kalicinski, and I'll
show you how app links, a new
feature in Android Marshmallow,
lets you do just that.
Now, there are two
conditions an app needs
to meet in order to get rid
of the disambiguation dialogue
for good.
One, it has to be
configured to handle
URLs pointing to your website.
And two, you must
be able to prove
that you control the domain
under which your site is
hosted.
Let me show you how to do it.
First, look at your
Android manifest file
and make sure that you
have at least one activity
with an intent filter that
matches the following.
For the data element, it
uses an HTTP or HTTPS scheme
with your domain as the host.
It also needs to
have a view action
and the browsable category.
If you've implemented deep
linking in your app before,
you might notice that you have
that part configured already.
There's one more detail you need
for enabling app links, though,
and that's the new
autoVerify attribute.
So make sure you
add this as well.
This will tell the system to
kick off domain verification
when your app is installed.
Let me walk you through
that last step now.
In order to associate
your site with your app,
you will need to put a
digital asset links JSON
file on this exact path under
your website's root directory.
The format of the file is
pretty straightforward.
You can just copy the sample
from our documentation
and replace the two highlighted
values with your apps package
name and the fingerprint of
your signing certificate.
You should leave the other
fields exactly as shown here.
Be careful if you're using
a different certificate
or package name for
your debug build,
or you will run
into problems later.
Also, make sure the file you
create is accessible over HTTPS
as that's the only way Android
will be able to successfully
verify the connection.
Now, how do you test if
everything is working properly?
Just install your
app on the device
like you normally would
using adb, Android
Studio, or any other method.
Then tap on the link to
your website from any app.
Or you can issue a command
through adb that will
start the appropriate intent.
Observe what happens next.
If you set up both parts-- the
intent filters and the JSON
file-- correctly, your app
should launch immediately.
If you do see a
disambiguation dialogue,
that means the package
installer wasn't
able to verify your domain.
You can use the
digital asset links
tool to see if your JSON file is
reachable and parsed correctly.
With these simple steps,
you can make life easier
for your users.
So go and implement
app links now,
or check out the
other great features
that we're introducing
in Android Marshmallow.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]